SuperDuper Bella pepper pepper pepper
loopy Bell better people are better
better better okay oh I know wow I'm a
wizard pick up items with the left
trigger holy [ __ ] I got a staff and
a hand with glowy's on it all the wizard
hair grid hello everybody my name is
markiplier and I can't see you because
I'm in the Wizarding World of left hand
path this is my left hand it may look
like it's on the right for you you'd but
you'd be wrong because on my left now in
left hand path this is a world where
magic is real look at that magic I just
did blue even the voices in the distance
are responding to the siren call of my
magic oh I love my mails God got a good
manicure
hey wow that was not a book the well of
all reward awaits you once in the well
left trigger to summon arcane power and
grasp items left pad to blink what wait
oh those were two different sentences
left pad to blink right application
button for menu and difficulty settings
health is ruins remaining on your left
hand saves happen on death or at the
screaming at us at any old screaming
head at a screaming head not the
screaming head
we who watch wish your soul well we who
watch apparently bled all over this
sheet of paper why was that necessary to
send the stairs to enter the well who
will Heidi die dijo here we [ __ ] go
la dee [ __ ] where's my goddamn desk
how close am I to you guys you tell me
I'm bumping I bumped something oh I've
got magic shooting out of my door
Oh boink Wow okay no huh no why don't
you start giving us some light oh yeah
Zed yeah left hand well man I gotta I
gotta create a new character here wait
oh this will immediately oh never mind
Oh arachnophobia code replaces spider
like enemies with non spider like ones i
Rebecca recommend only enabling this if
you really can't enjoy a game without it
well I mean if you guys don't like
spiders I'm sorry I have Tripta phobia
if you have arachnophobia we're all just
gonna tough this through I wore the
phobia hat in our latest charity
livestream so I think you guys can get
through this because I believe in you
for whatever that matters low terror
mode for less intense with less scary
experience Oh big [ __ ] baby the needs
of this table don't look at me now I'm
not gonna enable it okay all right Zed
sign whatever Zed means it's truly
dangerous heavens forfend you'll ever
face those dangers but if you do
blinking away will be your greatest
friend okay you'll need to clap as this
here's a danger now don't try and fight
hey thanks hey all right blow your every
move Wow
you didn't tell me out oh how doing oh
oh there's a new sign be careful with it
it's called v s-- v sh dangerous it's
dangerous to your photo
bass bass bass bass whoops obese goes
here oh I get it I am a wizard look at
me wizard I'm gonna wizard you know BAM
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you're dead to go I can
sense it mmm yeah I am so oh I got so
much potential know as wise we still
what we learned
oh well done ah ah my brains I can teach
you when you're edgy aha look desk oh
hang on I got to really think about this
what the hell oh cool
this game really cool okay I'm sorry
this game is really cool is it still
running
all right cool I don't know why but this
games really cool and what's this white
light oh oh it's still blue all right
never mind then I'm gonna go over to the
table hey how's it going sweet table
thing Jaron I've got gem right here
you're talking about jam Ram oh wait
hang on this you're talking about this
wait no this ah Jai Ram Jai Ram husk
humors greater spells of funniness you
talking about are you talking about
improv guys wait I've got the most
powerful spell of all
it's still a viable way oh oh I'm sorry
look that there's a task I need to see
through uh-huh we will continue later
okay all right well all right then well
I'm a beautiful young wizard and you see
so much potential in me is what I heard
about that one I know a simple stroke of
magic thus Z will banish the dark all
right so I'll stroke your magic thusly
swim swam WOM ooh wait no Oh baby I got
the magic Oh No look at this fireball Oh
Oh what is that
oh wow Oh wham baby whoa hey whoa watch
yourself bring your dog to your for
remember what you know oh do I remember
wait oh I think I'm getting a memory oh
there we are
spell of the laughing the greater spell
laughing bah oops sorry about that BA
hat crass arm pure magic ritual pebbles
D boo shooby wahby debit circle
protection some like this problem
okay sure won't go with that one whoa
whoa whoa
oh wow what is that hello wow that's
whoo that's terrifying
how about some true magic
[Music]
yeah that's a long way down what's in
here [ __ ] holy [ __ ] bags on a [ __ ]
stick
what heckinger heck scared the piss out
of me god damn it I'm sorry you alright
here let me draw you a nice circle oh
geez okay alright he's alright he's
gonna walk it off everybody's calm down
calm down now
everything's fine don't worry about it
how this game's cool this game also
feels good when I'm going through it
like it doesn't feel janky it doesn't
feel disorienting it doesn't feel
anything like that it's just like it's
very smooth and it works really well
you see me true magic oh this guy sees
me good thing I'm naked
hi anybody around the oh hey wait a
minute hey wait a minute
Oh some don't feel right about all the
will oh excuse me sorry about that some
don't feel right about all this alright
whatever you say what are you ah
friendly Danny fire the most basic of
human requirements can be used as a
common name lame No
ah ow my staff is on fire now that
doesn't seem good oh I meant to do that
I totally meant to do that excuse me can
I have you whoa I think he's watching me
this place just gets worse strange
noises outside the walls no windows
horrible sounds from the kitchen fire
screaming and pleading ever since and I
where the lightning struck and we heard
them both laughing I wonder if we died
that day if we're in hell and now he's
watching me I don't know why he would
when he says magic is so rare and
valuable but here's breathing at night
what she'd do if she found out I don't
even want to think I hope it's true I
hope we're only here for a little while
longer but I don't believe it
fascinating okay alright then fire okay
about firing the here fire like it love
it love it fire light the whole place on
fire everything on fire scares me fire
it's gotta be something I'm missing
right burn this down burn this down
hello oh uh hi hello can I just do one
of these maneuvers let me guys hang on
no not not today all right how do I open
you all right everybody hold on to your
hats it's about to get exploding in here
Oh No okay all right then I'm just like
oh there we go whoo this door does not
appear to open from this side okay you
know what yeah whoa how did I get all
the way here oh wait a minute
ah okay ah all right oh look at you look
at you man Oh
lower your head ow ow my head ow okay I
guess I'm down here now I don't know if
you guys could see me woo she's
beautiful who's in here oh I don't like
the look of that at all Oh who's there
huh alright okay alright okay who's here
huh
subject for male estimated age 45
acquired on road attempted robbery of
myself and my wife hmm
fire on the extremities no response
ingestion of vitriol no response subject
clearly in agony and fear of life but
Malakand does not respond and the void
remains unfulfilled sacrifice with
silver and moon and no response okay
he's dead oh he's very dead
hello you okay yo y'all right you okay
buddy you all right
kisses make everything better all right
let's go this way then I guess ooh
spooky
okay all right then ooh that's that's
not good that's okay
sorry Oh who's there oh uh don't come
any closer maybe I really tried to warn
you about that one that was a clear stay
clear stay here take this a fix you
right up there you go buddy okay never
mind then let's see a breakthrough as we
cut into the four made ill my husband
ever so reluctant but determined to cook
forced his way through the passage he
was clearly overcome with passion and
for the first time the void stirred it
was not enough but it seems the
connection is key stars an a nuisance
silver to attend Vic and copper knife
mcallen invoked twice before the release
still attempt to reproduce okay oh boy
here we go
Jack came consume those items which
respond to garam to reap husk from them
from B becomes power small Kostis all
the why should no begin with the key
make haste to lower your staff with that
the powers may form conjure mmm to the
east and that to the west okay I thought
I already did that okay
all right is that chamber pot there piss
on that oh hell yeah
I hope so let me get a look in there
yeah there's a [ __ ] all right well let
me a good chamberpot hello you splatoon
can I wear you on my hood no sorry I'm
out here let's go towards the blue flame
hello let's go towards the blue flame
whoa Iowa hi whoa whoa
whoa whoa
well one beer I'm time you were defeated
okay I'm dead now again I guess okay
well not exactly what I would call fair
all right whatever that was really
really cool I like that a lot so that
was the left-handed path not bad by any
stretch of the imagination definitely
deep into the fantasy aspects of things
which is something that I haven't seen
out of virtual reality it's normally
always horror but that was scary but
also really cool so I don't know if I'm
gonna play anymore for videos but that
was really nice so thank you everybody
so much for watching let me know if you
want to see more of this down in the
comments below and as always I'll see
you in the next video bye
[Music]